in Hong Kong the siege of a major
university is now in its seventh day as
police surround a small number of
anti-government protesters holed up
inside police say they will not try to
storm the campus again following
violence last weekend it comes on the
eve of local elections the first public
election since the pro-democracy
movement began ramie Inocencio is in
Hong Kong this morning rainy good
morning good morning it's estimated
maybe only as many as 50 protesters are
still barricaded inside Hong Kong
Polytechnic University about 1,000
protesters have already been arrested or
ID'd in the past week Hong Kong's police
chief is now calling for a peaceful
resolution reminding everyone inside to
think of their family this was Hong Kong
Polytechnic at the start of this week
police firing nearly 1,500 teargas
canisters anti-government protesters
responding with fire bombs for offence
and barricades for defense this is the
University now a near ghost town with
its undefended roadblocks and unlit
Molotov cocktails an SOS call for help
made of helmets and towels belies the
silence this man has been cooking for
his fellow protesters in the school
canteen now he's calling on his brothers
to leave the few people left here are
now just hiding in this maze of
buildings and rooms across campus with
the protest movement now in its sixth
month US university programs in Hong
Kong have sent dozens of their students
packing I think what really scared me
was when the protests started reaching
university campuses nineteen-year-old
Anoushka Srivastava left on a flight
today after her program linked to the
university of southern california
canceled physical classes for online
courses
she says her safety was a growing
concern
there's tear gas right like I think a
hundred to two hundred meters from my
dorm so just you know being in that
tense environment makes me scared and
that has been affecting my education to
some degree as well and Georgetown and
Syracuse University have also suspended
their Hong Kong programs looking ahead
to Sunday this city holds local council
elections those will be a referendum on
the government and the protest movement
and pro-democracy candidates are
expected to win in a landslide for CBS
this morning Saturday Ramey Inocencio
Hong Kong